jimmy chris congratulations guys you
made it through the first two rounds of
our 200th fortune fire competition now
in this final round we're sending you
both back to your home forges to build
an iconic weapon from the forge and fire
vault just like the rest of this
competition we asked the fans what they
wanted you to build now they had the
choice between the spadroon the darcher
gunshi
and the hunga manga
well gentlemen with 45 of the vote
fans have spoken the two of you guys are
going back to your home forges to build
the dark tree gun shy
featured in season seven of fortune fire
the darb shriek gun shy is a
double-handed sword originally from 18th
century thailand this five foot long
single edge blade was designed to
destroy enemies with deadly blows and
slashes
the signature flames and valleys of the
spine proved the difficult challenge for
previous competitors however one smith's
decision to put slippery rabbit fur on
the handle grip ultimately cost him the
competition
play smith good luck we will see you in
four days good luck man good luck got it
my name is chris moss i'm 34 years old
and i am a full-time knife maker
when i started making knives people
thought i was a freak this competition
made knife making cool
keeping with the 200th episode i want to
put 200 layers of damascus in my blade
so i forged them to the same size clean
up the edges weld them together and now
i have 200 layers forging is done get
this started
the quenching is always nerve-racking
you could literally snap your blade in
half
all right here goes something
definitely a little bit of a nail biter
now we're good that is a huge relief
looks good got to get this thing put
together bird fits on all of my
components for the handle are done and
ready to be assembled now i get to the
point that i've been dreading
i've got to put these flames in i used a
finer marker for this let's make it
flamey single slip of the grinder and i
could fail parameters
we should be good man i'm so glad to be
done with these flames this weapon is
massive it's fitting for the 200th
episode i'm ready to see what it can do
my name is jimmy coronado 38 years old
i'm a full-time groundskeeper and a
part-time bladesmith
it feels great to be part of the 200th
episode i'm here to have some fun make
some blades and hopefully take home some
money i have my billets all welded up
that i can get a nice twist going in
each of my billets
and now i'm going to take the billet and
weld them together and forage my blade
out of that i'm attempting the canister
pommel and i forged out the numbers two
zero zero and i put them inside the
canister hoping that when i forge it all
out i should get a nice 200 visible
there inside the pommel but while
grinding i found a very slight warp i
need to get this warp out of my blade
but if something goes wrong here i don't
know what i'll do this the last day i
could be out of this competition
end result blade came out straight and
then it worked like a charm
i did it
it's done
now i cannot wait to see this thing
be destroyed or destroy something
bladesmiths welcome to our 200th kill
test
in honor of our 200th competition we're
bringing back two of our favorite
ballistic dummies the lovely medusa and
our snakehead band and our bluer than
blue dummy of the north
jimmy you're up first you ready for this
absolutely right let's do this
[Music]
hey
all right jimmy let's talk about your
dark [ __ ] gunshot here first up the
handle construction you have it all void
enough to where when i wrap my hand
around it it's a good grip and it's a
very light weapon now your blade had a
little bit of a warp but it is sharp and
overall sir
you will kill thank you sir
all right chris it's your turn are you
ready
yeah all right let's do this
[Music]
all right chris
first up it cuts deep because it's a
wieldable weapon
the edge is very sharp no marks
whatsoever and overall sir your weapon
it will kill thank you sir
all right gentlemen 200 competitions
that's almost 400 smiths that have had
their blades go through art's strength
test
today we're going to turn it up with a
fan favorite the skull shop but not just
one skull
six skulls
jimmy you're up first you ready have fun
dave okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right jimmy uh your blade took some
small rolls here but
the blade is in the same shape it
started out with good job thank you sir
all right chris you're up ready
give it all she got
all right chris blade held up
still in one piece still solid
well done thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the sharpness
test the multiple target slice
jimmy you're up first you ready for this
yes sir all right
all right jimmy there is one dull spot
here which i think might have got caught
up on the second to last of the
ballistics tubes but all of the rest of
the cuts are super sharp so nice job
thank you
all right chris you're up next you ready
give it all she got all right
[Music]
all right chris well as you can see
great cuts on all of the media up there
and all this thing is uh it's on hell of
a cutter nice job thank you
guys this has been exciting our fans
have put you through a very difficult
challenge but you guys came with your a
games ready and gave us beautiful blades
but the time has come to decide which
one of you is taking home the 200th
fortune fire champion title and that
check for 10 000
the winner of the 200th fortune fire
competition is
chris congratulations
now jimmy you rocked it the entire way
but unfortunately your time in this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor
i'm disappointed but uh i gave it all i
could and um chris's blade just
performed a little bit better
chris
congratulations you are the 200th
fortune fire champion you just got
yourself a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations thank you thank
you
all of these obstacles that the fans
have put in our way and they
consistently picked something that would
be awesome and really hard it's what i
would want to see
i just won the 200th competition of
forged in fire
you